do I believe that work ethic is a
foundational piece of success yes I do
do I want anybody ever to work so much
that they get depressed of course not
[Music]
garyvee on hustle fine look I think that
you always have to sleep in the bed that
you make and so I'm aware that I've been
disproportionately passionate over the
last decade around hustle and hard work
right like you know when I wrote crush
it there was so much of that in 2009 I
thought there was an amazing opportunity
of the internet YouTube social media
that was true people benefit from it
both of you many who are watching yeah I
mean I think look I think it's sad when
you get to a place in your career where
you can drive traffic for others by just
the sheer mention up and yeah it's not
fun to be the subject of articles or he
knows where people are taking things and
not painting and wagging just yeah it's
just not the full picture it's very
clear if you read or watch anything for
even more than five minutes that I want
people to be happy and be self-aware do
I believe that work ethic is a
foundational piece of success yes I do
do I want anybody ever to work so much
that they get depressed
of course not I you know I never think
that money is the driver and so I think
I think whether it's lazy headline
reading we're not doing for work yes
it's not been it's not been the most fun
to get dragged you know I yeah I was
like
you know and there there's so many
people who are proof of the words that
you say me included so listen there's a
byproduct of success you know where
people will you know hustle porns a term
leverage or is a term leverage preneur
is when you're using other people to
build yourself up at the cost of the
other person and you know I think that
though you know as you get bigger people
who leverage you and I'm okay with that
because the truth always wins in the end
and you know I know the body of work
that I put out my intent and if you want
to clip one thing or one definitive
statement from one talk without the
context of the whole thing of course you
can say anybody says anything but the
reality is is that you know I I believe
work ethic is important if you want to
achieve hyperbolic success I don't want
to tell people how to be happy yeah so
why are you telling me how I should be
happy and there's plenty of people that
are super depressed that work forty
hours a week
like it's just hyperbolized link baiting
leverage renewing and I'm ok with that
but at the same token it's important not
to not take other people's points of
view into account and I'm I'm in a
constant you know focus of that as well
[Music]
you know a lot of people asked how much
do you sleep and my answer six seven or
eight hours and it [ __ ] with people
right because they think I'm sleeping
like an hour and my point there is
sleeps important like I don't know like
who thinks they're gonna survive without
sleep sleeps important what's important
for what I'm about is what you're doing
when you're awake I'm fascinated by
people who like say I hustle I sleep for
hours but then watch three hours of
YouTube videos a day right and so for me
as you know and what you're referring to
as somebody who interacts with me is you
know Tyler sending you emails like can
you do 11:30 p.m. to 12:30 p.m.
I'm every minute I have is programmed
11:15 Oh 25 yeah no look I mean the
amount of five and seven and ten and
thirteen like I basically Tyler what I
see your face what do you think it's
eight the eight o'clock until 11 p.m. is
pretty much programmed to the minute
with zero slots for anything but the
next meeting but I'm working out right
but like for like work eight to eleven
with zero lunch zero downtime like if I
go take a piss I'm cutting into some
meeting now but here's the thing here's
the thing that's matching my happiness
and ambition that is not for 99.9% of
people I time management needs to be
predicated on what makes you happy and
what is coming out of your mouth the
biggest thing I'm worried about is
people are talking big game but then
their actions don't match it so to me
it's happiness first and then
eliminating hypocrisy and that's how I
think about it so for me it's that
because I love this game it's what I
would want to do and my ambitions are
great and I enjoy it I want to spend
9:00 p.m. to 10:00 p.m. on a meeting to
build what I'm building it's it's what I
love to do it's no different than being
in the studio or painting or you know
it's just what I love to do so first of
all it's different for everybody right
but what I would say hustle is to me is
that when you have passion around
something that you were squeezing every
last bit of the juice out of the orange
right to me Hustle is maximizing the
energy you're putting into somebody I'm
blown away by people saying that they're
hustling and they want to achieve these
great things and then their actions
don't match it's like saying you really
want to lose weight while eating a Big
Mac right so to me hustle would be
putting all your effort into achieving
the goal at hand and for me that
it's making every minute count hiring a
full-time assistant who's ever I mean
Friday night didn't happen because I was
hustling like every minute like if I
miss my 15 minutes to tape the show I've
missed my 15 minutes because there's so
much hustle my day there's no you know
there's no like hey I there's no hanging
out there's no like time we're like if I
get to do like one joke with you guys as
I'm walking in between meetings we like
to find out to be like a rare
acquaintance situation like like
currents not acquaintances Hustle is
putting it all in a line Hustle is
waking up one day the day before you die
and realizing you gave it your all into
the parenting of your children the
building of your businesses the fur lamp
that you wanted to do whatever you
define it's just you know all-in
emotionally and executional II in theory
and strategy and an execution I get very
upset when people try to suppress people
from hard-working without realizing that
that's what makes that person happy and
you know whether it's me or Jason
Frieden and DHH like I think we actually
agree on most things I think the thing
we probably would I'm curious in a
sit-down is you know is it up to us to
know when Dan or Johnny or Susan are on
the verge of burnout and or do we know
like telling people like you should work
40 hours a week or 160 hours a week
eliminates knowing what they're about I
don't know it's to say I think none of
us get to sit on an ivory tower and tell
people what to do you know do I believe
that hard work is an essential part of
the kind of success that people define I
do do I think working so many hours that
it burns you out that you need to retire
or quit or you're unhappy and perpetuity
is bad of course I do I think this is a
self-awareness game and actually I think
it's a much more interesting game of
like do you know why you're working or
what are you trying to achieve I would
go crazy sitting on a farm in Middle
America or doing 28 weeks of vacation
snot what makes me happy but I
unbelievable II am happy for the people
that makes it
happy I love the process of building
something the way I want to build it I
would go crazy having all people working
remotely the way 37signals does they
would go crazy managing a thousand
people under a roof I think it's about
self-awareness
[Music]
I've never fault I've actually never
fallen a spider mutant okay no like
we're all gonna just myself and honestly
by the way I'm getting a lot more 7 & 6
7 & 8
then anybody would imagine and on
weekends I'll go 11
I think sleep is now we're getting the
truth okay so you actually give yourself
a lot of recovery what I'm doing is
Monday through Friday no question that
game can be six and you know and and
seven and when I play basketball it
could be even a little earlier because
we have a 6:00 a.m. tip-off so I get up
at 5:30 but but I almost consistently
will try to make up time Friday night to
Saturday Saturday night to Sunday Sunday
like I just don't know like it's just
I'm a big believer that's all yeah but
now I'm not worried about what people
how much sleep they get I'm worried
about what they do while they're awake
okay but the two things are connected
because if you wake up fully recharged
it means you wake up ready to take on
the world you know that feeling you wake
up and you say come on bring it on it
doesn't matter how many obstacles
challenges setbacks said I prefer those
things okay perfect well you know Travis
is a friend of yours I just joined the
board of uber Travis has a little bit of
that it's like he may be dealing with 30
crises at the same time he eats a for
lunch and what happens and here's the
kid who just put something on your
facebook yes sir that I love which is it
sounds completely just busyness that's
it it's not life and death the people
who have a hard time are the people who
basically make it too important its
respective is everything
[Music]